this film tourists Eichmann diseases
grease creams now I just want to watch
it - watching a green screen stuff I
think this is the second once there's at
least one more he's creative his likes
it have a shower where's Sharon Hanley
and somebody comes out and confirms that
this is all canon yeah Sharon is in the
picture at the end of the shining
somewhere that I got to collaborate with
film theory so filmed there you can do a
video chaired
and then when you go back on movie
fights you can pitch the Jarrod's oh
there we go get all the different movie
characters you're gonna have to be the
MCU anymore it's perfect
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba John old
is my name
no John come on John Humphrey Oh Jared
from Y scratch we're doing the shining
video yeah
oh here's John hungry we're gonna watch
from wisecrack Y The Shining creeps us
out Kubrick in perspective what if
emitter with wisecrack actually if I
hear they're an amazing film channel do
you enjoy wisecrack alive over at our
patreon we do TV show reactions for many
issues including weekly Q&A is one of
our top reward tiers is whatever video
you request we must definitely cover
usually a reaction no one has faith in
our discussions just off of the
brainstorm talk is big especially David
Gandy who drove six hours to come to a
live event and listen to us talk for an
hour and a half like nah I'm only
interested in hearing you talk if it's
about a video you do a reaction to
they're not gonna give you some topic to
cover David I hope you know we're only
joking I'm not I've been serious this
whole time let's watch this video
woo John knows this my dream casting for
Solid Snake is Jack Nicholson just so
you can go Natalie
it's been years since I've heard you do
that by inner child enjoy what's up guys
hallo season continues out wisecracks so
last month we piloted a show called the
film tourists it was on the wolf of Wall
Street if you haven't seen that one yet
be sure to check it out this is the
second episode in that series this one
is on the shining before we get to it
this video is small-scale moving I
curated online cinema streaming
exceptional films from around the globe
movie at your 30-day free trial at movie
comm slash wise records interesting
might actually check that out okay
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining or the
world's most persuasive argument for
taking the stairs this movie scares the
[ __ ] out of everyone but except Stephen
King
[Music]
it's cuz whoa damn wrong with this place
is it haunted doll on their heads is it
possessed by the devil
Tony something about an Indian burial
ground
that's really cool yeah a lot of
tradition interested for the part easy
to understand reason to [ __ ] our pants
The Shining deliberately avoids an
easily describable premise and this is
part of what makes it so damn horrifying
it deprives us of the logical
explanation Kubrick accomplishes this in
a variety of ways but I'm here at the
Overlook Hotel surprising this is cooler
than ready player one most effective
ways to create a strong sense of
perspective how Don is framed and
sequence see a shot can be objective
subjective or fall somewhere in between
okay
purely objective shots show us a scene
as it is a God's eye point of view as if
we're eavesdropping or watching a play
subjective angels directly insert us
into the action showing the view from
just beside or behind a curve purely
subjective cuts take us directly into
the eyes of a character that's cold
usually by showing their face first
followed by their visual perspective or
emotional experience
Bob can also invite us to question what
we're seeing we see a shot of Danny's
face then a cut to the girls then
Danny's face again with this simple
sequence of shots we're being shown the
events through Danny's mind let's see
how Kubrick takes this basic principle
perspective there that in sterile
Swahili and he's always in the bathroom
considered jamesina any writings
tricycle through the hotel's winding
portals Kubrick is able to achieve
supernaturally smooth movements to
follow Danny the hotel from a child's
point of view want to get like a
Calliope hello Danny
in a traditional subjective shop that
emphasizes his experience navigating a
large maze like hotel but don't follow
him perfectly watch how the camera
leaders after he's left frame and then
hurries to catch up with him what a film
scholar calls this the wandering camera
because the camera ambles along like its
own sentient being or here and imagine
monster stalking Danny through the halls
this creates the sense the hotel is
alive and watching Danny through his
shitty vacation when the twins show up
we move more intimately into a
subjective sequence of Danny's POV
flashing between his bloody visions
Danny covers his eyes looks again and
now they're gone so perhaps the girls
are just in his head by starting with
Danny's point of view as we follow him
but then shift into a possible camera
monsters point of view and then back to
Danny's maybe unreliable own vision the
film undermines our ability to interpret
the events in front of us whose point of
view is this to any's the hotel some
demon now let's consider jack is all
this creepy stuff in his head - did
someone just spike the water with LS
man's worse than wine Hotel ABS mail
take the scene in the apparently empty
gold ballroom in the scene we go from a
close-up of Jack as the seemingly
addresses an invisible being the reveal
shot of Lloyd this subreddit of
sequencing of shots could suggest that
Jack is hallucinating
just when we're sure that this is all a
subjective delusion Kubrick moves the
camera backward over his shoulder
taking the shot from his direct point of
view to a more objective one from there
Kubrick gives the scene an objective
reality by showing both characters and a
shot together Lloyd's the real deal we
think until Wendy she lit up a ballroom
suddenly empty and will act totally
confused and creeped out so what's going
on we don't know and the camera work
makes sure we'll never find out now at
times Jack's point of view even seems to
merge with that of the imagined predator
that was following Danny in this shot
Jack's view looking down on the model
hedge maze blends into an aerial view of
his family wandering through he actual
edges this effect happens again as he
chases Danny in the final scene
see how the same kind of shot that used
to be stalking Danny through the halls
has now mingled with Jack's point of
view further confounding the various
supernatural elements of the film we're
not having point of view mr. Kubrick
also uses our perception of physical
space to creep us out how do you make a
huge otherwise normal hotel and present
it as a claustrophobic nightmare Kubrick
is famous for what is called one-point
perspective which adds to the cram pool
with one-point perspective near perfect
symmetry draws the audience's eye to the
one vanishing point at the center of the
frame giving the sensation that we're
being drawn into the shot which is
further enhanced by the tracking shot
anyway it feels uneasy like the walls
are collapsing inwards hereditary we
feel increasingly cramped as the movie
goes on almost like claustrophobic Ranch
which can occur when people are
together by juxtaposing large spaces
with much smaller ones Kubrick is able
to get the viewer to feel really
claustrophobic just starts with the
opening shot of the mountain which cuts
to the shot of the family clown Carson
then we had from the large sweeping
hotel lobby to the Torrance's small
hotel quarters while the hotel may be
large the Torrance's are trapped in
increasingly smaller spaces within it
eventually Jack ends up locked in a
fridge
Danny escapes through a tiny window and
nobody has any elbow room through these
trips and perspectives stanley kubrick
is able to add a layer of creepiness
that evades simple description and
that's why the shining is so great
Oh Bill nerds will continue to talk
about it for years to come
there's so much more to talk about in
the shining so if you like this video
let us know if you want us to do another
and as always thanks for watching
peace
alright guys hope you enjoyed that we
got a couple more into the year so this
episode is brought to you by movie those
of you listen to our movie podcast you
know the movie has been gracious enough
to support us there as well because of
them were able to continue making
episodes with film tourists so movie is
a curated online cinema that focuses on
prestige films festival hits and beloved
classics there are always 30 perfectly
curated movies on the site every day
they present a new film and every day
they take one away movies are really
great to offer those three red eyes
recently movie has been featuring the
works of Hong Kong filmmaker Johnny Toth
was famous for making really awesome
gangster films I watched the film Triad
election in college and it catapulted my
love for Hong Kong cinema that movie is
playing now on movie along with other
Johnny Joe films like Detective no I
mean like I've seen a number of their
videos but this is next-level everything
that's pretty cool you know one of my
bras or Netflix and [ __ ] is like I'm
just you need options I and they're not
Jersey I'm like whoa 30 and they're like
hand-picked and they're considered
prestige to awesome films I'm pretty
good range between like classics and
Newsday and they'd say switch them out
every day oh that's that's pretty sweet
and like it's working it's working on me
well done wisecrack you were killing the
game graduations wisecrack I'm gonna
movie it's a sentient camera trick is
that is that like in Evil Dead when the
camera is that the famous camera Sean
said to you a lid or like when it's in
the house and ashes knocking over
everything oh that's pretty cool yeah I
was like a little film school that we
have here I'm all time I watch this
video I just can't think in hereditary
borrowed every day
like why the space yeah one thing I've
always appreciated about wisecrack is
they do break stuff down I'm used to
them being more philosophical about
things so on this coin it's nice to see
them doing something that's like oh yeah
like a microfilm school because now
you've heard the shining broken down a
thousand times but to actually focus in
on the camera work and the look and the
way the tone of the movie is making us
feel because it's a good point like it's
hard to describe the shining for what
makes it what it isn't for what makes it
so effective and I thought they did a
really good breakdown holy [ __ ] any time
you appeared inside of the blue hat man
I was like I guess not that big with you
already pair one take a Spielberg peg I
thought that was why his YouTube channel
could do it whoa I must not be too
challenging there's a split second where
my mind wandered off going but could you
do that green screen effect like a Paul
Greengrass movie yeah because there's so
many of the frames here very still or
like very fluid so it's easier to be in
frame yeah you do know I I don't know
from experience doing it but from what I
do know it seems like it's difficult to
insert somebody into a wide-angle if
it's moving at all yeah so like somebody
like Kubrick who keeps things pretty
locked off for certain shots yeah
because I was thinking about that too I
was like he's posed in ways that fit the
angles it looks like he's there yeah in
this video I don't know how much time
this took but I assume that a good
amount of craftsmanship and ingenuity
had to go into this yeah I feel like out
of all these physical space is the one
that I'm not even sure if you might be
able to categorize in a lot of movies a
shot that is physical space or the
directors actually thinking adverse it
just happened to be physical space yes
just naturally if you're shooting in
places sometimes just make a shot that's
physical space you know they're like
every shot has to have a plan and a
design and I'm firmly over the mind that
yes some of them do and
some of them were probably just kind of
self conscious decisions that you had to
make in a pinch yeah that are just in
uniform with the overall tone see the
thing about Kubrick is like I would not
be surprised at all if every one of
these shots was intentionally choosing
each one of these techniques and aspects
oh god yeah I doubt any of this was like
things like what this is not what we
agreed upon frame this up I want it
symmetrical
are you doing Kubrick was known to be
like yeah we're gonna do this just take
50 times I'm gonna make Scatman Crothers
cry today he was to his nuts when it
came to being a perfectionist
have you seen Eyes Wide Shut yeah lassic
the one-point perspective that's like
all up in hereditary well yes that is
similarly visually crafted and it has
that similar quality of like so much of
the movie is like really deliberate in
their life camera motions that seem very
composed and very choreographed yeah
intentional that's another movie where
it seems like nothing is just thrown out
there and speaking of like objective and
subjective shooting it makes me flash to
the movie AI because Spielberg loves to
shoot in the master frame he loves to
use the objective framing you like you
choose where you want to look your
period on them yeah that's it Kubrick
was originally supposed to do a oh
that's right yeah Haley Joel Osment
dodged a bullet there poor kids so
watching this video and thinking about
like well yes Kubrick is known to do a
lot of this type of stylistic choices
and makes me think about how is Phil
Berger primarily very different movie
while Steven Spielberg is also a
craftsman I don't think he's anywhere
near as anal yeah when I think of POV I
usually just think of that shot
first-person point of view what I
thought was neat was breaking down how
fluidly Kubrick can put you into the
persons POV without doing first-person
point of view you know just suggested by
how he cut
I thought that sequence at the bar was
great like just focusing on Jack
Nicholson watch the expression light up
cut to the guy at the bar and then pull
the camera back that way it's like
you're kind of deciding for yourself
right there but then you eventually
realize that it is that but or even when
he's seen the girls how of Danny by the
way who I think is one of the most
underrated child performances and film
ya history yeah like whenever people are
talking about like great child
performances no one really brings up
this kid when anytime I watch this movie
I'm like it feels so real heard the
strange stuff yeah like it's still we
have he's like a real kid and he seems
genuinely it's more than just knowing
how to transplant you through editing
that certain type of visual storing of
getting into their POV like switching in
and out of perspectives throughout the
film which I never liked most of this I
never really was able to pick up on it
put it over exciting so watching this
videos like that's pretty oh yeah well
because part of the point too is that
way if the movie is doing its job right
you're not supposed to notice or be
thinking about those things it's only in
the going back and you know tooth
combing it there's so many things that
make a movie like this effective I mean
there's music there are performances
there's production design there are you
know story elements that are scary I
really appreciate it the way they
highlighted how so much of the technical
side of the movie the construction and
especially the camera choices helped to
make the movie what it is and as scary
as it is and as palpable and intense as
it is because you do realize that like
they are effortlessly kind of
transitioning you into different kinds
of scenes that scene at the bar you
start out one way and then you kind of
transition into another approach to
shooting that scene and I feel like
that's kind of how you hopefully would
break down a script especially if you
have a long dialogue scene you know you
choose how you want to shoot the
different parts of it it really seems
like yeah they were able to fluidly kind
of concoct all this wisecrack
this is like a necessary video for
aspiring filmmakers I thank them you
know like this is uh this is brilliant
Thank You wisecrack thanks for telling
me about movie yeah you guys can't
subscribe to wisecrack oh thanks David
Gandy Frick
this yeah really by the way David Gandy
I don't know if you guys know this you
don't he's this mofo has been doing a
Taekwondo lately correct me if I'm wrong
David right now I believe I suggested
Taekwondo and you like ended up taking
it on okay now he he's like been testing
and stuff and he's going like five days
a week that means he has to call you
sensei right yeah you were the one who
gave him the push but I'm sexually
abusive that's my problem
well yeah you gotta clear that up you
can't be a sensei if you're gonna be
doing this you can't make jokes anymore
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification Bell check us out on
the Internet bye